hello in this video i'd like to explain
the k-mean cluster analysis in a simple
way
we will start with the question what is
the k-mean cluster
and at the end i will show you how you
can easily calculate
the k-mean cluster online with data tab
my name is matthias and i am the founder
of data tab
and now let's start what is the k-mean
cluster analysis
the k-mean cluster analysis is one of
the simplest
and most common methods for cluster
analysis
the k-mean method clusters your data
points
on a given number of clusters that is
really important
you must define the numbers of your
clusters before let's say
we have a data set and we want to
cluster
this data set into these three clusters
then we need the k-mean cluster analysis
how does the k-mean cluster analysis
work you can explain
the k-mean cluster method with these
five
simple steps and now let's start with
the first step
define the number of clusters the first
step in the k-mean cluster methods
is to define the number of clusters to
find the groups or clusters
the number of clusters must be defined
the number of clusters is the k in k
means
in our case we simply select three
clusters so
in this example k was selected equal to
three
after defining the number of clusters we
set
the cluster centers random each of the
centuries
now represents one cluster
now we have selected the number of
clusters and
we set the cluster's center randomly and
we can come to the next step in the next
step we assign
each point to the clusters let's start
with one point
now the distance from the first point to
each of the cluster centuries
is measured let's have a look at this
point
and we measure the distance from this
point
to each of the cluster centroids
afterwards the point is assigned to this
cluster
which is closest to it in this case
the distance between this point and this
cluster
is the smallest so we will assign
this point to the yellow cluster this is
now repeated for all
further points so at the end we have one
yellow cluster
one red cluster and one green cluster
then all points are initially assigned
to a cluster
we have defined the number of clusters
we have assigned
the cluster centroid randomly in this
space and we have assigned each of the
point
to one cluster now we can calculate the
center of each
cluster so we can calculate the center
of the clusters
for the green points for the yellow
points and
for the red points the center of each
cluster
is calculated these centers are the new
sentries for the clusters that means
that we simply shift
the centroids into the cluster center
so the cluster centroids are moved to
the cluster
centers in the fifth step we assign
the points to the new clusters since the
sentries can now be located at a
different point
each point is again assigned to the
cluster that is closer to it
this was our initial condition now
the center of the cluster is moved and
for sure now we can assign again
the points to the cluster which is
closest to them
and this will be our new cluster
now we have finished with all steps and
we do
one final step we will repeat step 4
and 5. now steps 4 and 5 are repeated
until the cluster distribution does not
change anymore calculate the center of
each cluster
assign cluster centroid to the center
and assign the points to the new cluster
if the clusters do not change in one
iteration
the procedure is over and in the final
step we move the clusters
to the new center in this step
the cluster will not change anymore in a
new iteration
a big disadvantage of the k-means method
is
that the final results depends very much
on which initial clusters was used
to take this into account the whole
procedure
is carried out several times different
randomly
chosen starting points are then used for
each of the calculations
since the cluster is used which has the
smallest
sum of distances between the cluster
center
and the points each time we use
different starting points it could be
that the outcome is different
so we do the whole cluster analysis
several times in
order to get the best possible result
data tab
for example do the cluster analysis 10
times
with 10 different randomly chosen
starting points
and then at the end select the best
cluster so
what is the optimal cluster number with
each
new cluster the summed distance in the
clusters become
smaller and smaller so if we had a look
at this picture where we have two
clusters and
this picture where we have three
clusters for sure
these three clusters does fit the data
better
than these two clusters and the distance
between the points and the clusters is
in this case higher than
in this case if there are as many
clusters as points
for sure the outcome will be zero now
the question is
how many clusters should be used to
answer this question
we use the album method again with
each additional cluster the summed
distance between the points
and the cluster center becomes smaller
and smaller
however there is a cluster number from
which each
additional cluster reduces the sum
distance only
slightly this point is used as a number
of the cluster so if we have a
look at this plot we can see that
there's a
big gap between cluster number one and
two
and there's also a big gap between the
number of clusters two
and three but there's only a small
gap between number of clusters three
and four so in this case we will select
three as a number of clusters and now
i'd like to show you how we can
easily calculate a k-mean cluster
analysis
online with data tab to do this please
visit
datatab.net and click on statistics
calculator
because we want to calculate a cluster
analysis simply select
cluster in order to use your own data
you can
clear the table and then copy your own
data into this table
i will simply use example data so
we want to calculate a k-means cluster
analysis
and let's say we want to analysis
salary and age now we can define
the number of clusters and
if we enter the number of clusters data
tab
will calculate the whole method
so here we can see the three clusters
with the centuries and you can
here we can see the elbow methods in
this case
it will indicate us that we can use two
as a number of clusters we have select
three
so we can change it in order to get the
right number of clusters
but let's go through the results first
so
here we can see how many points are
assigned to the different clusters
so and here we get the plot with the
different clusters
here we can see one cluster here we can
see one cluster
and here we can see one cluster and
further we get a table where we allocate
each point to a cluster
so but now if we choose two
as the number of clusters and we get
the new results and we can see here
in this plot that we have one cluster
here and
one cluster here and we can see that the
two clusters
fits the data quite well thanks for
watching this video
i hope you liked it and see you soon bye